good afternoon ladies and gentlemen you
the lucky people
who got in to this afternoon's great
event welcome I'm Paul Kennedy I'm deal
with professor of history at Yale and
directive in national security studies
it's my great honor on behalf of the
Office of Public Affairs which
administers the point of fellowship and
journalism that Yale to welcome you all
and to welcome our special guest of
course one could say this is a guest who
needs no introduction but the
formalities of Yale require that at
least as a brief introduction for more
than 35 years now the point of
fellowship has brought a distinguished
journalist to to this campus and offered
an opportunity to for students to
interact with the guest mr. bracha was
good enough to have a meeting with our
student journalists of which we have
just about 3,000 or 4,000 among the
undergraduate body alone and have lunch
with President 11 I should say please
before I go any further those of you
with cell phones beepers global
satellite transmitter anything anything
which makes a noise ladies and gentlemen
to do try to zap it kill it get rid of
it now where I to give a full
introduction to this distinguished NBC
News special correspondent I would take
most of his time he is a legend in the
field he stepped down after 22 years as
the anchor and managing editor of NBC
Nightly News he has as you know been
distinguished him by such an array of
prizes and awards in recognition of this
inquiry of mind and his keen
of knowledge and this broadness of his
scope whether it is to deal with his
documentary series anchoring the long
war which is a war on terror but it is
dealing with issues of racism in our
society I'm skipping I mean I yeah I
think the only thing he doesn't yet have
as the Victoria Cross that's because he
isn't a British citizen but he has
virtually virtually every everything
else he's going to talk to us on the
future of journalism which is a topic of
immense concern in this day of the
telecommunications electronic revolution
I like him not only because I have met
him and known him personally but I also
greatly admire his work on the greatest
generation is his his book and the
subsequent books and so it is with a
distinct personal pleasure as well as
being the faculty member honored to
invite Tom that I asked him to come up
the stairs as I go down the stairs and
to talk with you they'll be
approximately we understand about 30
minutes for his remarks and then I'm we
under cutthroat orders to stop things at
six o'clock because he does have to move
on to his lord knows ninth engagement of
the day again thank you for coming
welcome to Yale welcome to this pointer
lecture ladies and gentlemen
thank you all very much I can't tell you
what it means to me to have
distinguished historian like Paul
Kennedy introduced me I am in many ways
grateful that the head of a political
science department at the University of
South Dakota was a wonderful mr. chips
kind of character taught there for more
than 50 years he was my mentor in the
Metro a lot of governors and Senators
and rhodes scholars who helped me get
through what can best be described as an
undergraduate as an uncertain time
graduating in six years on the four-year
plan but nonetheless emerging with my
degree well in hand and later in life
when i began to get some recognition
from colleges and universities across
america one of the first of them
Washington University in st. Louis award
me an honorary degree called bill Farber
to get some background on my
undergraduate education and he kept them
off very quickly and he's had quite
honest he said we thought the first
agree that we gave mr. Brokaw was an
honorary degree
I have an enormous attachment to Yale
for a variety of reasons I was a guest
lecturer here during my Today Show days
he got to know the late Bart Giamatti
which was a privilege to have him as a
friend and to be in the presence of this
great figure not only in academia but of
course in his great love of baseball on
the zest that he brought to life and
when he retired from the presidency at
Yale I came up and did a lengthy
interview for him about him for that
evenings nightly news and as I was able
to say to him later I think it's the
only time on Nightly News in which we
gave more than two minutes to Dante's
Inferno because that was his great area
of expertise and then in 1998 I was
honored to be the class day speaker at
Yale and I spoke that spring for the
first time publicly about a book that
would be coming out that fall that I had
written called the greatest generation
and I talked to the students about their
grandparents who were in the audience
and who were members of that generation
and it was for me a very moving
experience because the students the
class of nineteen ninety-eight came to
me afterward and said I had no idea and
then of course that fall I published the
book hoping that the greatest generation
would find some reason to like it having
no idea that it would have the impact
that it did across the generations and
on this country and it has been for me
the most gratifying experience really of
my professional life but I say in all
honesty that I was just a doorman i just
opened the door and said this way please
there are some stories here that you
need to hear and from a personal point
of view no compliment meant more to me
than the compliment that came from the
late walter cronkite who of course
covered world war two and he came to me
when the book first came out and said
all of us who went through that
experience could not have written that
with the same perspective that you did
because you
an appreciation that we would not
completely have had we had a memorial
service for Walter recently in New York
fifteen hundred people showed up at
Lincoln Center will never be another
testimonial to an American journalist
quite like that one it was for all of us
who were there who admired him from a
foreign were privileged a column friend
a kind of passage if you will of a great
American and what he represented
especially in the firmament of
television news and all that he came to
represent there was no American
journalist I believe in the history of
this country who covered more big events
than Walter Cronkite did World War 2 the
Cold War the Kennedy election the
Kennedy assassination landing on the
moon the turmoil of 1968 Vietnam and yet
at his core he remained this
enthusiastic man who was born in
Missouri and race and Texas and started
his career in Kansas City he just loved
the business of journalism and took it
so seriously and I'm a beneficiary of
that because Walter Cronkite and Chet
Huntley and David Brinkley our founding
fathers created an expectation among
Americans about what the news ought to
be like on a nightly basis and I was
able to leave my working-class
environment South Dakota and join this
great great profession and see the world
in a way that I never could have
imagined when I was growing up back
there I would like to talk to you about
the future of American journalism why if
I may invoke your forbearance by going
back to a speech that I gave in the year
two thousand and one at the Kennedy
School in Harvard it was the Theodore
white lecture i'll use that as the
premise for the remarks that i want to
share with you but I also
and very happy to be able to now share
this speech with you the beginning of it
was a Yale audience because when I gave
the speech at Harvard it being Harvard I
had to speak much more slowly and use
much shorter words
there was a time not so very long ago
when in the early evening there were
only two news planets in the sky in
America the CBS Evening News with Walter
Cronkite and the hotly Berkeley report
on NBC all across the Republic and young
people in this room will have a hard
time realizing this all across this
continent at the dinner hour wherever it
was in the eastern time zone of the
central time zone of the Western time so
families would gather in South Dakota we
call it supper around the television
said to watch the news together to get
the first full account of what happened
that day not just in our country but
around the world I was a part of that
audience I was in an impressionable
teenager with a great interest in
American politics and what was going on
in the world and I had my nose press up
against the glass metaphorically of the
screen that delivered to our working
class living room images that had
happened that day in distant places it
was in many ways a transforming
experience because it expanded the
universe occupied not only by those of
us who lived in rural America but
millions of others across the television
landscape we were witnessed in our own
homes to the events that defined our
times wars political conventions and
elections national tragedies great
social causes the civil rights movement
led by dr. Martin Luther King never
would have happened was the same speed
it did without the place of network
television news to bind together this
country the great moral cause finally
recognizing the desperate need to do
something about racial inequality still
for all their illumination these two
planets the CBS Evening News on the NBC
Nightly News with shut and David also
had deep shadow
where other forms of life were not
nurtured racial issues were covered
extensively but gender issues were not
indeed very few women had any role in
reporting or in producing the network
news at the time the race for space was
a marquee event for those early network
broadcasts but the breathtaking advances
that were taking place simultaneously in
the health sciences were little noticed
in foreign news there was a heavy
reliance on Europe and the Middle East
but Asia apart from Vietnam it was a
little about the extraordinary political
and economic evolution beginning to
occur from Japan and Korea to singapore
and china remained a curious but very
closed society and almost no reporting
came out of it at home rock and roll was
treated if at all on the evening news is
a curiosity and not as the transforming
cultural event of the time the changing
role of the young is represented by the
largest most vigorous generation in the
history of mankind the baby boomers was
little notice outside of the political
protest context and it was a world a
prism if you will reflecting the
interest of people who made those
decisions all of whom happened to be
white middle-aged men from a common
culture along the eastern seaboard they
were serious professionals of
unquestioned integrity and intelligence
but they understandably reflected the
sensibilities of their time and place
they were my role models and they were
my mentors after all I aspired to be in
their place and I share their interest
as someone who expected to be a white
middle-aged man myself one day I was
content to follow their lead as I set
out of my own pilgrimage now back to the
future if I were that same teenager in
South Dakota and remember I made these
remarks in 2001 at Harvard I would have
access to three full throat
Networks three full-time cable news
channels and a local news channel as
well of two financial news cable
channels three sports networks a history
channel biography channel two cable
channels broadcasting public policy
discussions all day every day a
wide-ranging public broadcasting system
with its own evening news and an
award-winning documentary unit I could
watch the BBC News as well at ten
o'clock at night with a keystroke I
could call up more than 150 websites
devoted exclusively to news information
I could read the New York Times from my
laptop at home before leaving for school
I could check out the box score from my
high school teams basketball game in the
local paper from the night before and
think of how that world has expanded
since 2001 so one of our opening
questions needs to be which universe
best serves the public and the place of
journalism in a free society as grateful
as I am to the founding fathers of
broadcast news for their vision there
are standards and their commitment to
the idea of news on the new medium of
television I have to conclude that this
new medium and this new universe is a
richer more accessible and far-reaching
cosmos of news information and
communication to be sure the world in
which we now live in this universe of
information is in considerable chaos
it's still in its formative stages
imperfect in its many elements I
described it as the second big bang
there are planets out there colliding
with one another trying to determine
which ones will support life some of
them are drifting too close to the Sun
and burning up others are forming common
cause as we engage them in a process of
review and definition recommendation and
implementation some historic context is
an order first the new universe is more
egalitarian in every way than in a days
when a handful of press the Lord's
pursue their personal political agendas
William Randolph Hearst Colonel Robert
McCormick of the Chicago
tribune the Chandler's in Los Angeles
Henry Luce at time inc were in
journalism not just for public service
but for profit and the fulfillment of
personal ideologies edward r murrow was
an icon of those who followed him but
Walter Winchell was at least as
persuasive if not more so to his
audience which was at least as large as
edward r murrow if not more so we lived
through the oj simpson trial in our time
in the funeral of Princess Diana
recently the funeral Michael Jackson the
Lindbergh kidnapping trial the Sam
Sheppard murder case and the Norwich of
Wallis Simpson to the Duke of Windsor
created the same climate of frenzy in
those years we may have known too much
about Bill Clinton's sex life but not
enough about John Kennedy's Sunday
morning now has become a regular
appointment for students of American
politics and policy well beyond what it
was in the era when only meet the press
was on for a half an hour with Face the
Nation even as a quantitative expansion
of the new universe is breathtaking in
scope it is the qualitative nature of
this new reality that draws us to this
occasion and others does it represent a
step forward and the unending quest to
know better the perils and the
possibilities of the precious time that
we have in this life or is it simply a
retreat to the lowest common
denominators of public interest and
exploitation the short answer it is all
of the above just as analysis restaurant
you can find just about anything you
want the new viewer is empowered as
never before to explore a wide range of
interests to personally determine his or
her daily informational needs and
curiosities but for that viewer and that
reader and for those of us on the other
side of the screen or in the printing
press the old order of trusting
credibility integrity and independence
requires a constant and vigorous
reexamination especially true given the
pressures of time and the meteor shower
information real and imagined and
personal and professional lives it is
under assault every hour because of the
simple fact the new order has a
voracious appetite for something too
often anything to just fill the time
that in turn has led to what can only be
described as mob journalism it is not an
entirely new phenomenon the gathering of
all the parts of the journalistic tribe
around an event manufactured or
spontaneous it is seldom however
reporting in the classic sense it is
more closely akin to day care it is a
live camera a warm body and an event any
kind of an event however banal that may
or may not lead to something meaningful
or entertaining preferably the latter so
eight years after I made those remarks
at Harvard what questions remain how do
we begin to answer the questions
especially when the business model what
we call the traditional media newspapers
in print broadcast network news weekly
news magazines when that condition is in
such a perilous state let us begin with
that as we work our way through truths
and myths about the current and future
place of journalism in a free society
and what can only be described as a
colossal miscalculation of the new
realities those of us in the traditional
media print and electronic allow the
canard that information is free we allow
that to take hold in the generations
coming of age with a dazzling array of
instruments that their fingerprints the
plucked information effortlessly out of
the air or so it seemed information is
not free reporting and gathering the
news getting it into a coherent and
engaging form is an expensive process
very expensive when wars break out in
remote locales such as a rock or
Afghanistan very expensive
there's a national or international
crisis requiring extra additions or
non-stop commercial free coverage myth
number two journalism is dead in America
journalism is not dead the business of
journalism is on life support but the
daily and long-form work of
Correspondence and editors photographers
and graphic artist that goes on every
day generally at a very high level of
excellence and importance I'm on two
committees that judge journalistic
competition one of the committee's takes
a look at the work of young reporters 35
and younger the other one recognizes the
long career a body of work those
journalists who become the foot soldiers
of our profession in both roles I am
annually seeing a wide range of stories
and series that hit the highest marks of
our profession long investigative pieces
about the bush administration's
manipulation of the rules on torture a
lengthy series and global warming that
range from the Arctic and Antarctica to
the remote reaches of the undeveloped
world a brilliant narrative on the mind
of an arsonist another on the victim of
methamphetamines that plague in rural
America and on and on this was not just
in one year this has been year in and
year out for a decade now national
public radio and its commitment to long
series and important issues wherever
they're reflecting lives in societies
has never been more popular in America
enterprise journalism is being practiced
every day and we ought not to lose sight
of that however I do not appear before
you as a dreamy and unrealistic promoter
of practices that are unsustainable
journalism is undergoing the most
profound change in challenges of my
lifetime great journalistic enterprises
and entrepreneurial individuals are
working feverishly on new approaches to
the business of journalism fully aware
that the old order of dominant cash
spigots is over
websites are ever more important in ever
more wide-ranging and imaginative in
both print and broadcast parent
companies of print and electronic
outlets are pushing the limits on
sharing costs and content in an effort
to reduce the expenses of covering the
news and getting it into form in which
it is useful to you investigative
journalist cooperatives are now being
formed there's talk of expanding that
concept to cover political policy and
congressional delegations as individual
paper struggle to maintain Washington or
state capitol bureaus the arrival of the
electronic book instrument the Kindle
from amazon or the sony electronic book
has generated visions of collectives of
media outlets selling those instruments
and a daily download of their products
for a fee maybe as much as a hundred and
fifty dollars a year or more I wish I
could say that I have for you a crystal
ball and then I know how all this will
turn out I don't and I don't it is as
perplexing a problem as I have
encountered since someone once asked me
how the television picture got from my
studio to their home I do know this as
journalists we have to be much more
proactive in the promotion of journalism
as a critical component of our
democratic society for too long it has
been we talk you listen or we print and
you read and maybe if we're so moved
will print one of your letters the
culture of journalism has been as
important to the evolution of this
unique society as the rule of law and we
cannot let it wither we need to remind
our readers and viewers our fellow
citizens of that fact we need to engage
them in the future of journalism in my
lifetime alone can you imagine America
going to war against Germany and Japan
without journalism to document the
reasons and the progress or the setbacks
the cold war in which M
harkins can make decisions about the
wisdom of US policies based on what they
learn from the public press as opposed
to the Russians who were hapless pawns
of men and cardboard suits and despotic
minds dr. King in the civil rights
movement depended on journalism to
document the cruel inequalities they
were trying to address Watergate without
Woodward and Bernstein it would just be
another hotel in Washington Vietnam 1968
gay rights and women's rights
affirmative action and the Reagan
Revolution all the yeasty and momentous
developments of our age were shared
documented analyzed and disseminated by
journalists often imperfectly but over
the long run impressively the place of
journalism in a free society is not the
obligation of journalists alone society
all of us must do our part as well in
this new and confusing environment
viewers and readers may need more help
than they've had in the past I have a
few suggested guidelines to begin as
viewers and readers we must be as
vigilant in determining our sources of
information as we are about buying say a
flat-screen television set or a mobile
phone or a box of granola just because a
statement lands on your laptop or PDA
wael website does not make that
statement true that same vigilant is
required of the traditional media as
well and remember this most of all most
bloggers are not journalists there are
freelance commentators unrestrained by
the facts or editorial context and
integrity moreover most appear to have a
distinct agenda to advance or personal
grudges to exploit other sources of
information and news assembled on a
small screen The Huffington Post and The
Daily Beast for example are partly
original but they're mostly aggregators
collectors of information
gathered at some expense and effort by
traditional media this is not to suggest
that I wish the blogosphere would go
away I am a free speech advocate and I
enjoy this new Tom Paine environment we
are a land of many voices and minds and
more need to be heard but we do have a
common obligation to measure and examine
what they're saying and not just take it
in and be aroused by it to young people
especially those who have not yet bumped
up against the realities of the hard
work of using information as a tool to
take on the many vexing problems of our
rural I have another set of guidelines
remember this you will not solve global
climate change by hitting backspace you
will not eliminate third-world poverty
by hitting delete life is not a cut and
paste proposition these new instruments
of communication research commerce and
information are transformational tools
they require your heart and your mind as
well as your fingers on the keyboard
they are carriers of information and
news but they do not originate those
critical components of dialogue and
decision-making among free people these
principles are neither stayed or toxic
they are critical to the health of the
profession and in the bond between the
viewer and the reader and news producers
they have not disappeared but their
place seems to have been diminished in
the daily struggle to master this new
universe moreover I very strongly
believe the place of my medium in all of
its forms is so pervasive and so
influential it has a fundamental
obligation to receive as well as the
send in the past I have participated in
town hall meetings on the press and
phoenix in pittsburgh in minneapolis and
other cities I've never failed to come
away with a better understand
learning about vital but fragile link
between my side of the screen and the
viewers after almost 50 years in this
profession small towns and the world
stage during times of constitutional
crises Wars natural disasters of epic
proportions social and economic upheaval
scientific triumph sand great personal
tragedies I have one enduring and
primary conclusion the people take us
seriously and we fulfill our obligation
to them and our place when we return the
favor they are empowered and so are we
by the riches of this new universe we
occupy we have gone past that memorable
19th century Chicago newspaper credo
print the news and raise hell well that
remains of stirring rallying cry the
fact is that we live in a far more
complex world of news and information as
this new world takes shape beneath our
feet and before our eyes on a daily
basis we cannot just randomly stumble
forward guided only by instincts for
that day survival but neither can we be
dismissive of the appetite of viewers
and readers for a rich variety of
sources engaging Lee presented whether
serious or trivial we owe it to
ourselves how we're calling our time and
place to raise to a higher station a
constant and wide-ranging dialogue on
the place and conduct of this profession
that is so vital to a free people and I
hope in some small way that this evening
will be a part of that necessary
colloquy thank you all very much